allo ligny bonjour bonjour à la livrée
beau jour aux auditeurs de martinique la
première est aussi ceux qui nous
regardent via les réseaux sociaux
vous avez 53 ans vous êtes cadre
territorial de profession et vous allez
mener la liste pour un look l'inventaire
et cela c'est bien cela vous est très
connu dans le monde associatif et en
particulier dans le carnaval vous êtes
président entre autres du collectif des
opérateurs de rue
qu'est ce qui vous motive pourquoi vous
présente ira au loonie d'abord permettez
moi de dire de souhaiter la meilleure
année à nos compatriotes martinique et à
travers le monde singulièrement les
bâtiments des années cette année doit
être une plus belle année une année de
santé de prospérité d'un mot pour parler
de notre motivation parce que la
motivation des collective c'est celle là
de dire que en un certain nombre 1 de
manière significative de la mâtine loi
se sont mis à réfléchir se lamente un
qui ne lui ressemble plus lamentin qui a
perdu beaucoup de sa fertilité 1 au bout
de 30 ans de mandature soit que en
sommes responsables nous avons mis sur
dans un pot commun tous les tous les
points forts à mobiliser je crois que
c'est ensemble que nous avons décidé en
responsabilité d'agir voulait le
changement et la menthe
nous sommes le porte parole de la
majorité des citoyens laventinois qui
veulent effectivement un changement que
le l'inventaire autres son rayonnement
alors quelles sont vos relations avec
pays à parce que moi je me souviens que
vous ichi lors de la création de pays à
la très présent j'étais présent comme
beaucoup de citoyens martiniquaise
quoique quand il s'agit de construire et
c'est certain ça vient peut-être de mon
éducation dès qu'il s'agit de chaises
positive dès qu'il s'agit de contenus et
construire si je peux contribuer je le
fais en personne libre vous êtes
soutenus par pays a dans ce non nous
avons un mouvement qui est un mouvement
populaire ils m'ont fait l'honneur de me
de me désigner porte parole et je les
dis lors de la présentation ça s'est vu
lors de la présentation de notre liste
nous étions donc 2
des citoyens n'a menti noir vous dites
que le lamantin est passé de ville
fertile à wiltz terrils veux vous
expliquer le l'inventeur que nous avons
connu à l'entrée de pierre hanot même
avant déjà hier nous étions je vais
prendre un exemple nous étions en
réunion conviviale avec beaucoup de
citoyens et nous évoquions sur l'amant
terre rayonnant c'est là mon teint qui a
vu sur lamentin de bruges end ou ceux
qui connaissent se lamente un de la fête
de justice lamentin du ducale bastien
qui étaient à la croisée des chemins de
martinique où tout le monde où il y
avait de la vie
c'est cela montana s'est lamenté fait à
ty que nous voulons faire revivre
nous voulons faire en sorte que la
montée ville de 4165 habitants soit une
ville
deuxième de cette manif à que le
lamantin aussi reprenne sa place au sein
de l'acas m oui qu'est ce que ça veut
dire occasion-là le la montée n'a pas
une place prépondérante à peine je vais
je vais donc précisé j'ai dit qu'il faut
que lamentin obligeant positionnement
politique plus marqué à la cacem que ça
serve au maximum la population du
lamentin et je vais aussi précisé que
nous sommes paul entraide pour la
mutualisation des moyens pour la nôtre
place à la casse m pour l'existence même
de la cassette mais il est hors de
question pour nous que les citoyens d'un
manteau noir où vivent ce problème de la
pénurie d'eau qui s'est produit l'année
dernière
il est hors de question pour nous coller
parce que nous avons nous sommes en
train de rencontrer la population depuis
des années mais là j'ai l'impression que
les gens on l'apprend libérés ils sont
heureux de s'exprimer et de dire des
choses de proposer surtout d'exprimer
nos attentes
il ya un vrai problème de transparence
de lamentin il s'agit et je le dis j'ai
bien compris qu'il s'agit que de la
montée un positionnement politique
beaucoup plus marquée pour que l'acacia
vocia la population du lamentable
quels sont les grands axes de votre
programme qu'elles seront pendant cette
campagne vous priorité on va on va avant
je crois qu'il ya des actions à mener de
manière urgente
une fois en place d'abord rassemblé le
personnel municipal pour le faire
partager
n'est ce pas là notre projet de
mandature parce que je crois que la
force d'une politique municipale c'est
le personnel c'est l'appareil municipal
et très rapidement dans les 100 jours
on sera en mesure de produire un
organigramme qui fera que ce projet de
mandature le cap que nous allons donner
sera transformé en projet
d'administration et de services
et l'idée c'est de faire que ce
sentiment de sécurité qui en centre
ville très rapidement disparaissent par
une chose parce qu'un ouvrage aller vite
mais bien que la police municipale qui
en sous sol de la mairie dans des
conditions d'après ce que j'ai compris
d'hygiène pas tout à fait acceptable
soit placé en niveau directement presse
autre vide ensuite on va parler de
l'attractivité de ce centre bourg avec
un programme concerté avec les habitants
et les commerçants
nous ferons que cette ville a retrouvé
de la vie mais nous allons aller plus
loin sur la question de l'attractivité
de l'ensemble du territoire avec la
nouvelle collaboration des associations
des institutions et des privés oligny je
vous remercie
merci
[Musique]